what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
seven prediction video as you can see by
the title this is going to be a big one
after season six ended we currently have
two queens and three kings in the
television series we have Queen Cersei
Lannister and King's Landing
we have Queen Daenerys Targaryen who is
on our way to dragonstone most likely we
have King euron greyjoy of the Iron
Islands Johnson oh who is king of the
north and last but certainly not least
we have the night King beyond the wall
by the end of season seven one of these
characters will be dead most of you know
that history tends to repeat itself
quite often in this story there are a
lot of parallels from the past present
and future and given what we know from
all the previous seasons I think it's
very clear that once again next season a
king or queen must die so far a king or
queen has died in every single season of
Game of Thrones some seasons we have had
multiple kings and queens die and when I
was getting ready to make this video I
went back through all the seasons just
to see how many kings and queens
actually died in each season and by the
time I added them all up I was pretty
damn surprised at how many have actually
been killed in just six seasons and I'm
sure you definitely remember some of the
big moments in the show when some of
them have died but I think you may even
be surprised at the number I'm going to
go over all the ones that have died so
far then I'll tell you which king or
queen I think dies next season and why
if you'd rather just skip to the end and
get to the point then I'll put the clock
on the screen right now so you know
where to skip ahead to but I need all of
you to comment below and tell me which
one you think dies next season I'm very
curious to see what the majority of you
have to say the following of kings and
queens happens pretty quickly starting
in season 1 episode 7 King Robert
Baratheon who was taken down by a boar
after he missed his thrust due to having
one too many sips of that strong wine
thanks lands on Cersei season 2 episode
5 we see the fall of King Renly
Baratheon who was killed by a shadow
baby with the face of Stannis Baratheon
when I saw Melisandre give birth to this
thing it was one of those WTF moments in
the show but it was the fitting way for
Renly
getting penetrated from behind like that
during season 3 episode 9 we lose a king
and queen during the red wedding one of
the most shocking episodes in television
history still one of the best episodes
in the entire series sadly we lose the
king in the north Robb Stark and his
newlywed Queen Tulisa Stark not to
mention their unborn son Ned Stark 2.0
next up was King Joffrey Baratheon
during season 4 episode 2 and I think I
can speak for all of us when I say we
could not wait for this day to come
no tears were shed when this little
prick died unless they were tears of joy
of course the next king the fall was in
the very first episode of season 5 the
king-beyond-the-wall mance rayder
Mane's went out like a gangster after
refusing to kneel to Stannis Baratheon
we do not kneel but the fatal blow was
actually delivered by Jon Snow with an
arrow as man's was being burned alive by
Melisandre in season 5 episode 10 we
lose a king in a queen solis Baratheon
hangs herself shortly after her own
daughter was burned alive by Melisandre
solis was not able to live with the
decision that had been made and later in
that same episode Stannis finds himself
alone and wounded in the woods during
the battle for Winterfell Brienne of
Tarth finds him and executes him for the
murder of his brother Renly Baratheon
who she was sworn to protect
and speaking of kin slain the next king
to die was Balin Greyjoy who was
murdered by his own brother euron
greyjoy that has arrived after exile to
claim the Iron Islands for themselves
and we even see the Mad King die in
season six during a flashback scene we
have heard stories that Jaime Lannister
stabbing the Mad King in his back the
same king he was sworn to protect after
hearing about this moment in time for so
long it was cool to get a glimpse of
what actually went down that day and in
this season six finale we lose a king
and queen in the same episode for the
third time first add I was Margaery
Tyrell who was in the Sept of Baelor
with her brother Loras and her father
mace Tyrell and we all know what
happened next
Cersei decided to skip court and play
with fireworks instead moments later the
sept explodes into a green fire ball
while Cersei sips wine from her balcony
this leads to the death of the King
Tommen Baratheon Tommen watches in
complete shock
the sceptic knowing that Marjorie is
inside or was inside and it's too much
for him to handle so he decides he's had
enough of being ting so he steps inside
the windows frame and now he goes
falling to his death when you go through
the list again of all the kings and
queens that have died and every season
it is kind of shocking but I think
considering a king or queen has died in
each season we can be sure that another
one will die during season seven but the
question is which one maybe even more
than one is going to die during season
seven that has happened many times
before but who do you see dying next
season out of the remaining kings and
queens I dunno I think it's going to be
Daenerys that's going to die I know some
people think she will die at the wall
this season because of her vision at the
house of the undying
some people think since the wall is
coming down in season seven then
Daenerys needs to be there at the wall
and this is when she will die but I
think Daenerys will survive season seven
I do think Daenerys will die but not
until near the end of season eight and
what about Cersei Lannister will she be
the one to bite the dust next season and
keep this trend going I know most of the
entire fan base once Cersei to die
considering Cersei is running out of
allies and she's gaining even more
enemies it looks like she is almost out
of options it looks like it's going to
be hard for her to survive unless she
blows up King's Landing and flees the
scene
I think Cersei will survive season seven
as well though and that might not be a
popular belief but I believe that
somehow someway Cersei will be able to
persevere through all the madness and
live to fight another day in season
eight and how about the king in the
North Jon Snow does anyone actually see
him dying again this soon rumors are
that he could be on a dangerous mission
next season
maybe he dies going on that mission I
don't really think so Jon Snow is too
important of a character to die now his
character is key to the end game of this
series and they can't keep killing him
and bringing him back it would start to
devalue his character and the stakes
would never be high during a battle if
we knew he could come back every single
time no matter what Jon will definitely
make it to season eight alive but what
about the night king the true king
beyond the wall I think the answer is
pretty simple here he will not be killed
during season seven we know the war for
the dawn is coming in season eight so it
wouldn't make much sense to kill him
this
early when there was still so much
politics to tie up in the South before
this battle can happen so that only
leaves one person left the king that I
believe will fall during season 7 and
that is King euron greyjoy
out of these five kings and queens on
the show your honors the least developed
character and the one I see most likely
to die next season out of these
characters we are invested in him the
least and given the fact that they
haven't taken a time to flush out his
character he seems to be likely to die
just as fast as they brought him into
the fold he will be around long enough
to weaken Daenerys his army so that she
has to unite with John to overthrow him
and Cersei and then take on the knight
King in season 8 I don't want to get
into any spoilers in his video but I
think Theon Greyjoy could actually end
up killing you're on and I know people
probably see Theon as the unlikeliest of
heroes
but I think that's what it actually
makes sense for him to kill you're on
because most people wouldn't see that
coming and if you need more details
about how Theon could do this then watch
my video about beyond being the unlikely
hero there is spoilers in that video
though so proceed with caution
but if beyond isn't the one to kill
you're on then I think it could perhaps
be Jaime Lannister who kills you're on
during season seven
we know that Cersei and you're on both
need alliances right now and given these
two psychos personalities I can
definitely see them inlining themselves
with each other next season I've even
seen some videos saying that Cersei and
you're on may even get married to
strengthen this alliance I don't really
know about that but I do think Jaime
will end up having a serious problem
with this and given Euron's madness and
potential influence over Cersei
I can see Jaime killing him when he
crosses that line but these are just my
opinions but I do believe your on will
be the king that follows next season
comment below and tell me which king or
queen you think will die during season
seven one has died every year so I do
believe at least one or more will fall
next season to let me know which one you
think it is and why I want to thank all
of you for stopping by today I'm
watching this video I always appreciate
that and I also want to thank my
supporters over on patreon much love to
everyone seven blessings I'll see you
all down on the comments section bye